hi so this is Nikolas mum and dad he was
so proud very played very played indeed
tell us about growing up we were talking
a little bit earlier on about her
politics when did you first realize that
she was really into politics well really
about which was 16 when she first joined
SNP and ever since then she's just been
a really thing that's been our soul our
goal I know she trained as much lately
politics has been what she just wanted
to do what Raisa I to be honest I don't
know but she has immense drive
determination hard work a huge great
work ethic nick has always had so she
has driven she believes passionately in
what she's fighting for and I think that
that's quite obvious to see do she ever
bring you and say dad I don't what to do
about this
no what she never does no I've offered
my help
what about you mom under she ring you
she rings me every night and just to say
I'm home
how are you she always has done some she
left her meeting to go to university
she's a fantastic daughter she's caring
and always wants to know that we don't
care nuts sometimes all is just time on
you okay and that's it and that's that's
wonderful rough and tumble politics when
people are rude about it you want to say
don't be rude about my daughter yes and
do you ever hold myself back sometimes
especially not campaigning somebody else
here
what's that necklace dungeon don't start
oh that's difficult but just keep my
mouth closed as far as the campaign's
are going and and the debates how do you
think she's done I think she's done
marvelously well she's come out I think
I mean I'm biased obviously but you know
listening to other people who I think
she's commitment talk she's she's made
us immensely proud Scotland is it's
changing it's changed and it you know I
should I'm a mom but it's a no small
part due to her and as far as the
debates are concerned as a dad when you
watch her performing do you think that's
my girl
I do yes I do I'm biased as well but I
really think she she as I thought
performer
and the debate she's been very very good
what did she get her energy from I don't
know as I say she's always been very
driven very determined but today she has
certificate energy a belief she's
passionate about what she does and I
think when you're passionate about
something you get the energy the
energies of the year she believes and
what she's doing she's honest
down to earth but I don't know
working-class family what better
grounding does anybody need great to
talk to you about thank you very much
thanks a lot